what was the worst fashion moment on the
runway that were somewhat unforgivable
[Music]
they kick who was the word though maybe
those whose birth outfit its little
pancakes play friend oh girl I have to
give that to myself like I had the worst
fashion moment for sure that was tragic
I think that the tool will forever live
in my memory and probably yours too or
we could say my purple dress I'll
totally take right over that nothing in
the MENA web farm to runway girl good
course I'm popping the corn and I'm
feeding the children Lina absolutely
fell apart but at that point I was
getting eliminated getting under bands
oh wow
she has a creature from the Jersey Shore
with envy
yes oh my god sugar days hold off that
was a choice what the hell is it it was
terrible it was like a wrinkly old troll
doll that if it left out in the Sun too
long
I'm gonna burn it I'm gonna invite all
the kids to come and we're gonna dance
around it ever wonder what happened just
Smurfette Sugar's triple reveal this
wasn't about it I'm ready to cuddle up
by the fire in this gorgeous caftan
voila it is spring honey it was gorgeous
and it got worse
oh my runway looks when Michelle visage
called me a roach
something's bugging me about her outfit
honey you me tell you something what
somebody gave you you take what they say
and you make it beautiful definitely -
the Aries look so hopefully I did a
redemption for myself because that is
not my best track but it was a fun
moment for me you know watching on TV
I'm like what was I thinking marry wham
bam thank you
[Music]
[Applause]